Beckham's boy belts it out if every day  was Christmas I can't be with you on  Wednesday cruz beckham the 11 year old  son of victoria and David released his  very first single if every day was  Christmas and he heard it played on the  radio with Dad cheering him on nice all  proceeds from the song are going to  charity the little pop star in the  making was recently signed by scooter  braun Bieber's manager who went on the  defensive after piers morgan accused the  Beckham's of exploiting their kids your  children should go through schooling  right if you're famous parents without  being pushed into the commercial world  too early scooter took Pierce to task  writing how about you match him dollar  for dollar to the charity instead of  criticizing step up and help these kids  the way Cruz is Pierce responded stop  pretending this is about charity when  it's about promoting brand Beckham and  making you a ton of money off another  young kids back  [Music]